[Music]
is there a good at being sad partly
because my mom straight-up told me not
to be but this is sad man you got a John
Locke quote or piece of Conte and wisdom
you can throw at me
those guys were more focused on rules
and regulations for spiritual stuff you
got to turn to the east I'll take
anything you got hit me picture a wave
in the ocean now you can see it measure
it is height the way that some light
refracts when it passes through and it's
there and you can see it you know what
it is it's a wave and then he crashes in
the shore and it's gone but the water is
still there the wave was just a
different way for the water to be for a
little while
this one conception of death for a
Buddhist the wave returns to the ocean
[Music]
where it came from and where it's
supposed to be
not bad Buddhists no bird none of this
is bad
I need you to do me one last favor
mm-hmm say goodbye to me now and leave
before I wake up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can sit on that bench as long as
you'd like and whenever you're ready you
just walk through I'm ready
you